in practically every major world city
there are us tourists and business
people fighting to return many say the
State Department is providing little
information while the airlines are
offering exorbitant fares if the seats
are even available Don Dahler has that
story some of the thousands of Americans
stranded in Morocco are on their way
home today we spoke to two of them
Floridians Loren Davenport and Daniel
Fernandez before they left in other
countries we've heard that there were
only 24 hours it was a shock quickly
last night the US Embassy in Morocco
sent word that anyone wanting to leave
could get a seat on a charter flight
connecting through London for fourteen
hundred and eighty five dollars in some
cases that's twice with their original
ticket cost el Parcheesi says his family
of three can't afford it people we gonna
be talking about 3000's in Peru seven
students from Augusta University are
among more than a thousand trying to
figure out how to get home but there
were no flights available they're hoping
to get word from the US State Department
on what to do now we're gonna work to
get people back we're urging individuals
when they can't get back on their own
they traveled they're on their own when
they can get back they're on their own
they ought to try it to do that Loren
Davenport summed up the feelings of
thousands everyone wants to be home with
their loved ones President Trump said
yesterday that he will likely enlist the
services of the US military to get those
people out of Peru and we can report
that sources within the Pentagon tell us
that they are in fact working on such a
plan Don Dahler CBS News Newark Liberty
Airport so many people that want to get
home everybody main lows are in Mexico
right now and they're staying there
because they feel like they're there
safer right now they don't want to deal
with the airport and flying sitting
tight to see to see what happens as so
many of us are yeah for some people it's
uncertain though if they want to be back
how to do it when you look at that
financial call
as well but it's tough not to be with
your family yeah